the lawsuit between prince andrew and
virginia geffrey moves on
she claims he sexually assaulted her
when she was 17. allegations the duke of
york denies
last month she started a civil case
against him for this papers have to be
served and these documents from her
lawyers detail how that happened on the
26th of august someone carried the
papers to the prince's windsor home
royal lodge security turned them away
but the next day they were allowed to
leave the papers with the police officer
at the main gate a small but significant
step
they have served the proceedings they've
intimated that they exist to prince
andrew in a formal legal way
but prince andrew
because they are not
english corps scenes their american
court proceedings does not have to go to
the u.s
court
the duke's lawyers deny the papers have
been officially served
one of the problems is it's really hard
to get close to the prince he lives
about a mile down this road and there
are gates at every entrance virginia
jeffrey's lawyers say they posted papers
to his home here they emailed his office
and his legal team so in their eyes
proceedings can continue
a judge in new york will decide on
monday
prince andrew has been keeping a low
profile he stepped down from royal
duties over his links to sex offender
jeffrey epstein
one of america's most high-profile
lawyers himself accused by virginia
geffrey says the case should be
dismissed
in 2009 virginia gouffrey signed a
release
which precludes her from suing people
like me
and like prince andrew she acknowledged
that she couldn't sue me and dropped her
lawsuit the same release requires her to
drop her lawsuit against prince andrew
prince andrew is currently at balmoral
out of sight in the scottish countryside
but still the focus of uncomfortable
attention for the royal family
laura bundock sky news